They're equal to one
of our squared of two. The argument is in fact pretty
much identical to what we had in the probabilistic setting.
There's nothing uniquely
quantum about this at all.
In any case, what we find is that the original state is not a product state.
Notice that it's not important
that these two numbers here are one over squared of two.
All that matters is that
both values are non-zero.
This particular quantum state
is a very interesting one. It's an example of an
entangled state of two Qubits.
We'll talk more about
entanglement later in the series.
Entanglement can be complicated, particularly when we're
talking about quantum states in the general formulation
of quantum information,
but here in the simplified description of quantum information entanglement is equivalent to a lack of independence.
So for a quantum state vector,
if it's not a product state, it's an entangled state
and this particular state
is commonly viewed as
the archetypal example of an entangled quantum state.
And in fact, we sometimes
think about this state as representing one unit of entanglement, particularly when we're
thinking about entanglement
as a resource that can be
used to do interesting things.
The quantum state that
we just talked about is one of the four so-called bell states, which you can see here
along with the names
that are commonly used for these states, Phi plus, Phi minus,
Psi plus and Psi minus.
They're all entangled
and they do form a basis for the space of all
vectors representing states of two Qubits.
So these four vectors together
are called the Bell basis.
It's a very commonly
encountered collection of quantum states named
in honor of John Bell, who was a physicist who made
very important contributions
to the study of entanglement in the 1960s.
Here are a couple of well known examples of quantum states of three Qubits.
The first one is called a GHZ state.
It's kind of like the Phi
plus state that we just saw except for three Qubits instead of two.
And the second example is called a W state and it looks like you see here, so it's uniform over
the three binary strings
of length three that have
exactly one bit set to one.
Neither of these states is a product state and they both have interesting properties and arise pretty commonly as examples, so they're good to know about
and we will see them again.
Next we'll talk about
measurements of systems in quantum states.
Following the same reasoning
that we've been following this far in the lesson, which is to think about multiple systems
as if they're single systems. We immediately arrive at a description for how measurements of
multiple quantum systems work
provided that all of the
systems are measured.
That is if we have some
quantum state vector Psi that represents a quantum
state of an n-tuple systems
X1 through Xn and we measure
the entire compound system, which is equivalent to measuring
every one of the individual systems, then each possible n-tuple
of classical states will be the outcome of the measurement
with probability equal to
the absolute value squared of the entry of Psi that
corresponds to that n-tuple.
For example, if we have
a pair of systems XY in this quantum state right here, then if we measure both systems,
then we'll get the outcome zero hearts meaning zero for the measurement of X and hearts for the measurement of Y
with probability nine 25ths and we'll get the outcome one
speeds with probability 16/25.
That's really quite straightforward. We're essentially just ignoring the fact that these are two separate systems and we're viewing them as if
they're one single system,
but this raises the
following natural question, which we already considered
in the classical setting.
Suppose that we have two systems X and Y that are collectively
in some quantum state and we don't measure both, but
we only measure one system.
Let's say that we measure the system X and we do nothing to Y.
Of course, we can also ask what happens if we measure Y and not
X and more generally what happens if we have
three or more systems
and we measure some proper subset of them. But once we have an
answer to this question, we'll have answers to
those questions as well.
We know that in general
a quantum state vector of the pair XY takes the
form that you see right here, assuming as usual that sigma and gamma
are the classical state sets
of X and Y respectively.
The entries of this vector are
denoted by alpha ab ranging over all the possible choices of a and b,
and they can be any complex number that cause this vector
to be a unit vector.
Now we already know that if
both systems are measured, then we get the probabilities for the different possible outcomes